ومشاهدينا ننو للخبر العاجل نقلا عن
الشرطه الاسرائيليه اصابه شرطيين
اسرائيليين بعمليه دهس قرب حجز عسكري شمال
غرب القدس واطلاق النار على المنفذ والصور
التي نتابعها الان لموقع عمليه
[موسيقى]
الدهس
معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري
محمد اخر المعلومات المتوفره لديكم حول ما
حدث نعم هي عمليه دهس كما تقول الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وقعت عند معبر راس بدو في
منطقه مدينه القدس المحتله وتقول الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ان الشخصين اصيبا بجروح طفيفه
جراء هذه العمليه وتشير ايضا الى انها حيد
كما تقول منفذ هذه العمليه كما هناك حاله
استنفار كبيره جدا من قبل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وحرس الحدود في تلك المنطقه
كما هناك اخبار عاجله تشير الى ان طفله
فلسطينيه قد اطلق عليها الرصاص
وتوفيت في تلك المنطقه ايضا هذه اخبار
عاجله في وسائل الاعلام العبريه حتى الان
لا يعرف تفاصيل ما جرى تحديدا في المكان
لكن هنا حاله استنثار واضحه وهناك انباء
ان الشرطه اصابت منفذ هذه
العمليه بجروح لكن حتى الان ايضا لم تصدر
معلومات واضحه حول وضع الصحي لمنفذ هذه
العمليه وهويه منفذ
هذه العمليه حتى الان بمعنى حتى لو قالت
انها حيدت
المنفذ هو فقط اصيب لم
يقتل
يعني في في في في
غالبيه التفاصيل في في غالبيه الحوادث
كلمه تحيد هي اطلاق النار على المنفذ وعدم
وعدم تشكيله اي خطر على الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في المنطقه وفق هذا المصطلح
الذي تعم الشرطه الاسرائيليه في العاده
ولكن هذا لا يعني ان المنفذ على قيد
الحياه او لا يعرف بالضبط ما هو الوضع
الصحي لمنفذ لذلك يبقى الامر
راهن المعلومات التي تصدرها الشرطه
الاسرائيليه وكذلك المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
حول الموضوع لكن هناك تاكيد في وسائل
الاعلام العبريه ان طفله فلسطينيه تبلغ من
العمر ثلاث سنوات قد توفيت جراء اطلاق نار
خلال عمليه تحييد هذا المنفذ قد تكون
تعرضت لاطلاق نار على يد الشرطه
الاسرائيليه لذلك لان لان العمليه هي
عمليه دهس بالتالي لم تكن عمليه اطلاق نار
وفق المعلومات الاوليه والذي اطلق النار
في المكان هو الشرطه الاسرائيليه اثناء
تحييد منفذ العمليه فهناك احتمال كبير بان
تكون هذه الطفله قد قتلت على يد الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في المكان لكن هذه المعلومات
تبقى يعني غير واضحه حتى الان بشكل تام
وخلال طبعا خلال دقائق سلا بد ان تتضح هذه
الامور وكافه تفاصيل ما جرى خاصه ان
المنطقه الان يعني هي منطقه استنفار عسكري
اسرائيليه وتفاصيل ما جرى يبقى رهنا في
البيانات الاسرائيليه اي حتى
خلال الدقائق القادمه حسب اعتقادي يعني
حاله استنفار محمد ما الاجراءات تحديدا
التي اتخذت من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه بعد
هذه
العمليه الشرطه الاسرائيليه نصبت عددا من
الحواجز في المكان وتمنع حركه المرور
وكذلك حركه المشا في المنطقه وعملت قبل
قليل على تفتيش عدد من السيارات في سيارات
الفلسطينيين في في تلك المنطقه وهناك حاله
انتشار واسعه لحرس الحدود الاسرائيلي في
مكان العمليه في هذه الاثناء ويقال يعني
هناك انباء تشير الى انه جرى نقل المصابين
وهما مصابين بجروح طفيفه حتى الان ايضا
يعني هويه المصابين وم طبيعه هؤلاء
المصابين يعني هل هما من حرس الحدود او
الشرطه حتى الان لم تتضح هذه المعلومات
ولكن هناك واضح ان عمليه استنفار اي تبقى
مستمره حتى اعلان الشرطه الاسرائيليه
واجلاء جميع الجرحى من المكان
وكذلك اعلان ما جرى لمنفذ هذه العمليه كما
تقول الشرطه الاسرائيليه ونؤكد ايضا مره
اخرى ان الطفله الفلسطينيه التي التي يقول
الاعلام العبري انها قد توفيت هي طفله
فلسطينيه فعلا تبلغ من العمر ثلاث ثلاث
سنوات معك في المتابعه محمد خيري مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من تل ابيب شكرا لك